[Music]
oh hey
Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size 4 rest huh how you so big look at
the big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
down up on6 sorry about the mess hold
on
oh hey Bo hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burn me my wife and three kids have
you told them yet I'll tell them when
I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in 3
days this is crazy oh my God we're going
to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip stop collaborate and listen with a
new 5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in a
car can someone unlock the car
please call in
everybody I want him
found what was that little pothole
Maxi's been up the whole time by the
way where
that before I met your mom I was a
covert assassin I escaped at life and
now they found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
[Music]
us look at you playing the family man
I'm not playing this is my life
bang I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait wait
go new
record